breaking news relating to the corona
virus outbreak it has been confirmed
that there are two cases now in England
corona virus has spread to the UK the
flight carrying more than 80 Britons
evacuated is due to land any minute once
they touch down in the UK they'll be
taken immediately to a quarantine center
for a fortnight what happens to those
people making their way back from virus
affected areas symptomatic people have
not been allowed to board but those
without symptoms boarded a chartered
flight to RAF Brize Norton in
Oxfordshire the first plane to arrive
back in the UK had three military medics
on board as well as officials from
public health England and a special
isolation area for people who developed
symptoms after being screened for signs
of infection a script was read by medics
telling people to speak up if they felt
unwell it's unclear what will happen
with any future flights this one was
pretty empty only 83 other Britons in 27
foreign nationals got on board this huge
747 at RAF Brize Norton anyone with
symptoms are taken straight away to
hospital the rest got a coach to arrow
Park Hospital on the Wirral Merseyside -
an NHS isolation unit for the next 14
days the 83 UK citizens will be here in
quarantine
during this quarantine there are severe
restrictions to what patients can do and
where they can go treatment isn't
optional what the experts say goes and
if they develop symptoms they all
receive what we weren't considered to be
supportive care so they'll receive
support to make sure that they're able
to eat and drink properly and if not
they'll receive fluids into the vein and
they'll receive breathing support if
they need it so oxygen or maybe extra
supportive they were to deteriorate but
we don't have any specific treatment or
the virus itself so it's really just
supporting the individuals body until
they can fight off the virus themselves
but it's not all bad quarantine is
designed to be as comfortable
as possible that we fully furnished
rooms laundry facilities food and
self-catering kitchens
families will also be able to stay
together and everyone will have access
to a team of medical staff at the end of
the two weeks if the quarantine time
hasn't been extended freedom will be
restored and life can go back to normal
with a virus continuing to spread there
may be more quarantined to follow